[Musique]
radio classique
l'édito politique avec le figaro
guillaume tabard donc bonjour nadine
morano vous êtes invités politiques de
la matinale dont on parle évidemment de
l'intervention du premier ministre de
ses intentions et de l'arrivée au
parlement cet après midi je rappelle
aussi vous êtes évidemment sur la liste
européenne à des républicains
ça aussi c'est un sujet que nous allons
aborder mon cher guillaume tabard
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
hier à travers cette restitution curieux
mots le premier ministre a compris
quelque chose à ce que voulaient les
français et ce qu'on retiendra du
discours de 1er nice et bien sûr
l'expression exaspération fiscal un
expression forte qui rappelle un peu le
ras-le-bol fiscal qui avait diagnostiqué
pierre moscovici souhaite françois
hollande
au moins il n'est pas dans le déni alors
qu'on peut dire est mauvais esprits
diront que avait-on vraiment besoin de
trois mois de débats pour savoir que les
français voulaient payer moins d'impôts
en tout cas edouard philippe s'est fixé
une obligation de réponse et de mesures
fortes et lisible il a dit hier qu'il
avait reçu le message des français fort
et clair mais fera aussi que les
réponses soient reçus fort et clair ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya un
mois il m'était lui-même en garde contre
un risque déceptif des solutions qui
sortirait du grand débat aujourd'hui il
dit que hésiter serait une faute et que
tout frilosité serait impardonnable
clairement il met la barre très haut
c'est vrai sur les questions de
fiscalité c'est vrai aussi sur les
questions de démocratie
toute solution purement technique ou
homéopathique serait très mal reçue ça
ne suffirait pas autre précaution qu'il
faut avoir c'est que bien sûr ce grand
débat en soi était un succès 1 1 million
et demi de participants 2 millions de
contributions
ça n'est pas rien ça n'est pas rien mais
ça n'est pas non plus toute la france
pourrait me comparer ça aux 47 millions
d'électeurs inscrits sur les listes
électorales
et puis surtout ceux qui sont venus
c'est certain significatif mais ça n'est
pas non plus représentatif de la société
française clairement les participants
aux grands débats sont issus d'une
france plus diplômés que la moyenne tout
sur internet plus âgés que la moyenne
plus aisés aussi que la moyenne à
recettes françaises assurent elles
comptent mais elle n'est pas toute la
france
donc ce grand débat qui était une
réponse à la crise et gilet jaune n'est
pas en soi une réponse au gilet jaune et
le danger pour le gouvernement c'est en
croyant écouter ce qui s'est dit à ce
grand débat de finalement de ne pas
savoir se réconcilier avec l'ensemble de
la france en faisons un petit peu de
l'analyse non pas de texte mais de
mauvais évidemment tout le monde a
retenu exaspération fiscale mais on a
reçu aussi offensivement le mot
frilosité à ça s'adressait qui est oui
surtout que la publique arte cas ils
doivent payer pas dit effectivement
toute philosophie tout frilosité serait
impardonnable à mes yeux comme si
c'était lui qui disait ça est ce que
c'est un avis personnel est ce que c'est
une manière de mettre la pression sur
emmanuel macron en gros est ce qu aurait
d'un côté le monsieur plus qui serait le
premier ministre et l'autre côté un plus
prudents qu'ils seraient manuel macron
franchement je n'y crois pas d'abord ils
se sont vus lundi matin pour calais
cette intervention est du côté des
manuels macro on sait aussi qu'on dit
aussi qu'il a envie de prendre des
mesures très fortes et très
spectaculaire ce qui est vrai s'il ya
quand même un clivage réel au sein de la
majorité et au sein du gouvernement
entre ceux qui disent en gros il faut
moins d'impôts et moins de dépenses sont
plus économique une idée défendue
notamment par les ministres il y
sud-ouest un gérald darmanin bruno le
maire sébastien lecornu et d'autre et
puis une grande partie du groupe de la
république en marche qui est nettement
plus à gauche et qui est et très
méfiante à l'égard de mesures qu'on
pourrait qualifier de libéral
donc si bras de fer il ya mon avis ça
n'est pas tant entre le président et le
premier ministre contre l'exécutif et la
majorité
voilà magazine morano en direct merci
mon cher guillaume on se retrouve demain
radio classique l'invité de guillaume
durand
elle est que le figaro bonjour et
bienvenue vous êtes quatrième sur la
liste évidemment des républicains pour
les européennes on va parler de ces
élections européennes
cette restitution vous en pensez quoi
et il aura donc fallu que le
gouvernement dépense 12 millions d'euros
pour organiser ce grand débat passe des
mois à organiser des déplacements du
président qui ont tourné au one man show
de l'assemblée nationale pascal
perrineau d'ailleurs reconnaît lui-même
que ça posait un problème démocratique
il est tellement ces cinq tournées
encore une fois à alise organisation de
réunions de quartier comme le font
d'ailleurs régulièrement et normalement
tous les élus locaux et même les
parlementaires dans leur circonscription
voire quelquefois même à l'école des
fans enfin faire ce débat jusqu'à
organiser avec le présent la république
un débat avec des enfants le grotesque
n'a plus de limites en ce moment
l'assemblée nationale à une massive
baisse des impôts l'assemblée nationale
je continue est aujourd'hui paralysé
depuis des semaines et nous en sommes à
débattre sur le grand débat donc voilà
donc 12 millions d'euros de dépenses
pour organiser ce grand débat des
palabres pendant qu'ils ont duré des
heures et des heures et des mois puisque
ça fait quatre mois que nous y sommes
pour nous dire que les français en ont
ras-le-bol des impôts et b moi je pense
qu'ils auraient mieux fait de lire le
programme des républicains que nous
portons depuis des mois nous avions
alerté bien avant que ne démarrent ce ce
mouvement d gilet jaune et je constate
encore une fois que le premier ministre
edouard philippe n'a eu aucune marge de
manoeuvre hier puisqu'il est il est
resté dans un constat il n'ya pas une
fois où il a prononcé un mot sur ses
droits ou semaines vous savez il faut
laisser traîner en longueur maintenant
mellaza prend du temps tout ça mais
pourtant là
un homard des habs ça prend du temps non
mais peut-être que l'arrière d'abord
deux choses premièrement on a évoqué la
phrase de moscow logiciels et guillaume
tabard
on a évoqué aussi un quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy qui a commencé par des baisses
d'impôts qui finit par des hausses
d'impôts avec une crise majeure
full tilt est ce que j'en pense a dit le
contraire mais dans la conscience des
gens ils n'avaient ils ont l'impression
que depuis les trois quinquennats et on
intègre celui de macron il ya quand même
une sorte de zig zag ça va rappeler que
nous avions nous baisser les impôts et
qu'avec l'année nous sommes le sujet
j'étais membre de ce gouvernement à
l'époque nous sommes les seuls à avoir
traversé une crise économique mondiale
majeure ce qui n'a pas été le cas ni de
françois hollande ni même des manuels
matin que pour ceux qui auraient les
combats oublier j'aurai toutes les
conditions et d'ailleurs four hills mais
imaginons puisque dans le programme des
républicains qui se dessine à travers
évidemment non seulement des communiqués
mais la campagne des européennes ya à la
fois l'aspect et le volet européen puis
aussi le volet national et en dehors des
frontières
la grande question est que vous mettez
en avant c'est il faut baisser
massivement les impôts et il faut
réduire la dépense publique ans et
d'exactement les pistes d'edouard
philippe qu elle même a été pendant ses
mandats niquet nommé bourrier bon
écoutez il a été membre des républicains
il en est parti pour faire le contraire
de ce que nous annoncions depuis des
mois et des mois si le gp mais moi je ne
demande que ça pour les français je
demande à ce qu'il le fasse comme je
demande à ce qu'ils reviennent sur leur
faute politique majeure d'avoir
désindexer les road les retraites de nos
retraités sur l'inflation
vous le savez ça donc la même darmanin
disait dans le jdd la question se pose
non la question ne se pose pas elle
s'impose vous voyez ce que je veux dire
aujourd'hui on a neuf millions de
retraités qui ont perdu en moyenne sur
un an 400 euros de pouvoir d'achat
nous voulons et nous demandons que cette
injustice soit réparée
il faut ré indexer les retraites sur
l'inflation et de tous les retraités
parce que j'en ai marre que dans ce pays
on laisse entendre que parce que dans un
couple il ya une retraite de 1500 plus
1500 et soit à 3000 euros
on les fasse passer pour des riches
la retraite monsieur durand n'est pas
une allocation
ça n'est pas c'est un dû oui c'est un
dieu pour une vie de travail et donc
nous demandons cela comme nous demandons
la réindexation sur les allocations
familiales parce que l'autre cible et
l'autre victime depuis françois hollande
de catégorie ce sont les familles nous
voulons aussi que nous remontions sur le
plateau du quotient familial la question
madame morano sur le problème des
économies tout le monde c'est enfin une
grande partie des économistes qui ne
faut pas avoir cette pression de
rétention là que le grande manière de
faire des économies c'est de reculer
l'âge de la retraite
est-ce que du côté des républicains on
est d'accord sur cette idée qu'il
faudrait peut-être dire comme françois
fillon l'avait proposé pendant la
campagne elle va passer de 62 à 65 ans
parce que c'est ça où il va y avoir des
économies massives
ce qui pousse à y avoir avec lui permet
d aider d des postes d'économies
il y en a dans beaucoup d'endroits et je
peux vous dire que je vous réponds quand
vous voyez que les dépenses publiques
ont augmenté entre 2018 et 2019 de 44
milliards
la d'euros et que sous françois hollande
s'était 22 milliards vous voyez que la
trajectoire de dépenses publiques ne
fait qu'augmenter soum selon emmanuel
macron maintenant pour répondre sur ce
sur cette ligne spécifique des retraites
nous ce que nous proposons c'est
d'ailleurs pour ces d'abord plus
d'équité entre le régime des retraites
de la fonction publique et le privé
donc nous nous voulons aligner ses
régimes de retraite
est ce que nous constatons c'est que en
supprimant les régimes spéciaux de
retraite donc on est en arrivant vers
cette équité des systèmes de retraite
nous gagnons 5 milliards d'euros par an
donc ça nous l'avons estimé mais je vais
aller sur un autre ligne budgétaire si
vous voulez bien parce que on sacrifie
nos retraités également vous n'êtes pas
d'accord sur l'idée qu'il faudrait
allonger la durée légale de la vie des
155 6 mai comment fonctionne le système
par répartition c'est le nombre d'actifs
qui financeront de retraités dont
à partir du moment où vous avez un
allongement de la durée de la vie la
question peut être mis sur la table sont
avancés ce que semble-t-il pensé voir
philippe contrairement à ce que pensent
donc déjà à parler d'abord de non plus
d'équité
ensuite des bâtons du reste mais il faut
aussi l'autre pilier c'est le nombre
d'actifs le nombre d'actifs ça veut dire
qu'il faut aussi qu'on ait des enfants
voyez il faut que la natalité augmente
la natalité depuis deux ans régresse
donc si nous sacrifions notre politique
familiale et bien peut pas dire qu on
encouragera dans les décennies à venir
d'avoir plus d'actifs et ça je vous dire
nos partenaires européens sont très
étonné d'ailleurs en allemagne de voir
que nous sacrifions à ce point là notre
politique familiale qui était admirée
par tous en europe
est ce que j'avais le sentiment selon
bva est fait pour escamoter les
européennes oui oui ça traîne en
longueur
il n'y a pas d'issue d'ailleurs le
président en rajouter dans son agenda de
déplacements supplémentaires à en corse
avec avec les enfants il reçoit les
intellectuels mais tout simplement c'est
que nous payons en fait le manque
d'expérience du président qui n'avait
jamais vu un électeur de sa vie pour
l'instant il est c'est un peu match nul
dans les sondages avec laura son âme et
ce alors je vous dis allez même si la
lys à que vous représentez est en train
de progresser le reste à 14% et alors
moi j'ai franchement ces sondages
m'interpelle beaucoup parce que quand on
voit que depuis ça va faire deux ans que
manuel macron est au pouvoir
en deux ans dix ministres ont quitté le
gouvernement dont trois ministres d'état
ça fait cinq mois que la france tous les
samedis vit dans le chaos
la violence la destruction les policiers
caillassés attaqué et on mettrait
emmanuel macron pour le récompenser sur
la première marche des élections
européennes en vie donne un satisfecit
je n'ai pas pas lu devant c'est
peut-être qu'elle faisait des français
sont pour l'instant c'est ce que ben je
vois pas en quoi être pro européen donné
satisfecit à monsieur macron sur ce
qu'il représente sur la scène européenne
qui n'a jamais été autant divisée à
cause de la présence française je vous
rappelle que nous étions au bord de la
crise diplomatique avec l'italie et qui
considèrent viktor orban comme un ennemi
passé c'est dramatique et monsieur
monsieur mac aujourd'hui
un leadership sur la scène européenne je
suis sûr que vous avez lu le livre de
l'excellent lui de vigognes tout restera
en famille c'est évidemment un livre sur
l'état de la droite aujourd'hui on y
apprend notamment que gérald darmanin et
laurent wauquiez ne peuvent pas ce beef
et enfin ça c'est pas le sujet
fondamental non il ya un chapitre entier
est consacré à l'attitude de nicolas
sarkozy c'est vrai que il semblerait que
dans votre famille politique et dieu
sait que vous l'aimez nicolas sarkozy il
ya beaucoup de gens qui disent mais à
quoi joue t-il avec emmanuel macron d'un
côté il le voit souvent parfois même on
a l'impression qu'il le conseil sur les
heures supplémentaires sur l'aide de la
fusion par exemple du conseiller
départemental et du conseiller régional
et en même temps on voit leur ai dit des
indiscrétions de presse qui savent ça va
très mal se terminer
la quel est le jeu nicolas sarkozy
recèle la sphère civile dans cette
période l'attitude de nicolas sarkozy
est très claire vous n'êtes pas la seule
elle me semble en plus logique nicolas
sarkozy a été président de la république
de la france il a d'ailleurs été aussi
président de l'union européenne il
exerçait la présidence de l'union
européenne en 2008
donc c'est ça lui donne un rôle
institutionnel d'anciens présidents et
donc lorsque le président en exercice
pour accorder à françois hollande il
semblerait que le il semblerait que le
président en exercice l'invite mois au
regard de ce que jamais mais sur les
cérémonies commémoratives je ne pense
pas qu'il ne va pas bon ceci étant quand
nicolas sarkozy se rend sur le plateau
des glières à l'invitation de d'emmanuel
macron il est dans son rôle
institutionnel d'anciens présent la
république ensuite si le conseil oui le
fustigent mais l aveu cajole conseiller
quelqu'un c'est lui dire la vérité et je
pense que quand il
il s'entretient avec emmanuel macron il
vit dit la vérité de son analyse est
quand même bizarre mais laurence mortier
mais pas du matériel à des leaders de
l'opposition de voir quelqu'un qui a été
quand même pendant très longtemps son
mentor il est le président de coeur de
notre famille politique et je vous le
dis le 26 mai il se trompera pas quand
il faudra aller voter dans les urnes à
nicolas sarkozy comme il donnera
d'ailleurs un signe
au cours de ces élections européennes sa
famille politique
sa famille de pensée est ce que nous
défendons ce
on les valeurs de nicolas sarkozy faut
pas se tromper de bérat après quand
monsieur macron l'invité lui pose la
main sur le genou pour tenté de
l'instrumentaliser sur plateau des
glières ça ça le regarde mais je crois
que les électeurs les notre électorat a
bien conscience qui les entraîne à
présent la république veuille aussi
conseillé quand on fait appel à lui
c'est maintenant j'aimerais mieux qu'ils
écoutent un peu plus d'ailleurs on
serait pas dans cette situation est donc
vrai nicolas sarkozy n'est pas celui qui
voit souvent emmanuel macron mais celui
qui considère que ça va mal se terminer
le faisait mais c'est la même personne
lorsqu'il est rès de la république et au
moment de la manifestation contre
l'antisémitisme et qui dit devant toutes
les caméras de télé que dans ce pays il
n'y a plus d'autorité qu'il faut
retrouver de l'autorité il a été ancien
ministre de l'intérieur par ailleurs il
s'est donc ce que c'est que de gérer
l'autorité et notamment quand il ya eu
la crise des banlieues et bien jamais on
n'a vu la france dans cette situation et
pendant un si long délai c'est un
scandale
et ça il le dit publiquement et donc
quand ils pensent que ça se terminera
mal je crois que quelque part il n'a pas
tort quand je le lis dans la presse
parce que voilà la situation est devenue
intolérable c'est pour ça que maître
emmanuel macron 22%
j'ai du mal vraiment y croire merci
mille fois touche pas à mon sarko
c'était donc l'historial d'une certaine
manière de la dig morano ce matin la
vérité c'est d'abord ça sur l'antenne de
radio classique bonne journée à vous
gens peuvent pratiquer position sur
cette liste des républicains pour les
élections européennes qui auront lieu
donc à la fin du mois de mai c'est tout
proche c'est tout proche est tout proche
et 8h28 merci d'écouter radio classique
j'ai rendez vous avec michel grossiord
dans un instant avec thierry de
montbrial de l'ifri ce sont les 40 ans
de l'ifri est un grand institut consacré
aux relations internationales et nous
avons beaucoup de dossiers sur la table
madame mais voit emmanuel macron à 18h
ce soir il ya les élections en israël
beau